role is the CEO of superhuman
which I think I may be one of the top
power users of so we're going to talk
about uh
how the hell can we all do email better
but before we get to that I thought a
great place to start was just like why
is following a talk on Communications
email as a mechanism so important to
Startup Founders yeah
uh well I hope I have a good amount of
ventral display going on with this
jacket
don't look at me dude
so I get this question a lot is it worth
getting great at email what difference
does it make and
I'll answer the question about email but
I think this is also true generally
Sam Altman for example
a few years ago wrote a program to
compare the response times of the very
best Founders those who are running
billion dollar companies
with bad Founders those who were
struggling and who would eventually go
on to fail
it's probably no surprise that the bad
Founders took days to reply to emails
whereas the best Founders well they
replied in mere minutes
now you might think that's just about
impressing an investor
but as startups and we just heard we're
always on that's also true when it comes
to responsiveness
everything that we do sets the bar for
the organization almost nothing will
happen faster than we do it so if ever
you're sitting down thinking gosh
I just wish the team would do more or
move faster
we have to do more we have to move
faster now the magic is when you do that
when you respond to Twitter faster when
you respond to slack faster when you
respond to email faster your entire team
will do it too
let's talk about some of the tips and
tricks that you specifically use with
email you're probably one of the most
productive people I know on email you
built an entire company around this idea
how do you think about just triaging an
inbox and making sure that you are
responsive and quick and kind of timely
and don't let things drop through the
cracks
yeah boy well I have six tips or tricks
I want this to be as useful as possible
so I'll rattle these off quickly the
first one is
don't label or file your emails I see
people wasting a tremendous amount of
time on this it turns out that it's
faster to Archive and then search than
it is to pre-file your emails and go to
the folder or label and then scan
through it so just that one alone will
save you an hour a week
second one use keyboard shortcuts never
touch the mouse this may sound obvious
but even in this room it will shock you
how many people are still doing things
the slow way on the mouse let's say you
work a normal eight hour day
if you switch to keyboard shortcuts you
will save 134 hours over the course of a
year that's 17 work days every single
year
so that's shortcuts
number three I would say is well I've
seen inboxes as many as you can imagine
with hundreds thousands even millions of
emails in those inboxes
but why are we keeping these emails
lying around
it's out of a misplaced sense of guilt
that we might one day reply to them but
are you really going to reply to an
email that's older than a month although
it's older than a week I mean the answer
is no
and I happen to know some of the most
productive people in the world and guess
what they don't even try
so pick your personal email used by date
most of our customers pick one week and
archive everything older than that if
that sounds terrifying I'm sympathetic
to it you can say you know don't archive
the start email get yourself a bit more
control but it's crucial this will put
you within the stone's throw of inbox
zero
next one I would say is think about how
you're organizing your inbox so there's
roughly two ways
you can treat your inbox as an infinite
list and it's the unread emails that are
the things to do or
you can archive emails when they're done
and treat the entire inbox itself as the
to-do list
in the markers on red case
you end up having to meticulously
maintain that status and we've all done
this but just to make it real let's say
you receive an email and despite
yourself it looks really interesting you
open it you're like okay cool Mark is in
red then you're like oh there was one
more thing I wanted to check so you open
it again now you have to Market its own
red again
if you switch to the other method you
can avoid this archaic ritual just open
the email as many times as you want when
it's done archive it not only is that
faster because it takes you from n plus
one actions where n is the number of
times you mark it as unread
so just one action
it's also far less stressful because it
makes your inbox very uncluttered
first thing I would say is follow-up
reminders I know you use this a lot so
when you send an email
everyone in this room was sending very
important emails we're trying to close
candidates we're trying to close
meetings we're trying to close deals
but what do you do if the person doesn't
reply back
do you try and keep this all in your
head like some kind of rain man do you
painstakingly copy it to a to-do list
right one is inefficient the other is
ineffective
so what you do is when you send an email
just set a reminder for it to come back
if the person doesn't apply in let's say
two days
and that way you can stay on top of
dozens if not hundreds of conversations
and then the last thing
boy we don't just deal with email volume
we deal with email Variety in a normal
inbox
you have
urgent messages hiding behind Google
Docs notifications you have fyi's
obscuring critical time sensitive
opportunities you have calendar
notifications pushing things below the
fold
so if you were to process your inbox top
to bottom which by the way is what most
products of vertical Surf Clubs would
recommend that you do
you'll be Switching gears and that
switching of Gears that's context switch
overhead and it turns out that every
time we switch topic it takes our brain
about 20 minutes to recover I see some
nodding we've all experienced this and
get back to full efficacy so the
solution of course is to use and email
clients that really only superhuman does
this properly that can split your inbox
into coherent streams that you can
process independently
so I spent a lot of time trying to
figure this out I was telling someone
today I think I get 1500 emails a day
about half of those I could delete
another half of the half so 25
um I need to respond to in about 25
probably just need to read and don't
need to respond to how does superhuman
as a product actually help here and one
of the things for me is I used to have
tens of thousands of unread emails and
just said it like not get do them
good luck if you ain't hear from me in a
week like just email me again now much
better much more responsive and so talk
about just building the product and
constantly shipping new updates and
really trying to figure out like how do
you build a solution for the founders
for this
I think it starts with the observation
that responsiveness really matters time
saved really matters and what are we
solving backwards from
so
slight aside uh you know being as we're
all founders but building a company is
really really hard right most days suck
something has gone wrong shit's hit the
fan something's on fire that's a normal
day every now and then stuff goes well
and I had one of these moments actually
just a month or two ago we did an
analysis on 10 000 superhuman users
they're 30 days prior to using the
products versus their 30 days afterwards
and we were able to see that they are
responding to emails
twice as fast by rates because you can
actually even before you're using the
products we can look at the email
headers
and that they are responding to emails 8
to 12 hours faster and that's not by
accident that was by Design so we knew
that those were two numbers that we
wanted to drive
and we worked back from that so a good
example would be we talked about the
split inbox features so in this case
where you have half the emails you don't
even need to see and then of those there
are further streams what you would do in
the product is you turn on a feature
called important other and so that would
separate out all marketing emails or
promotional emails or automatic updates
e-commerce emails into a bucket called
other
and you'd have important which is just
person to person now so far so good this
isn't dramatically different from Gmail
or Outlook but how do you start
splitting out the rest well what I do is
I split out my Google Docs I split out
my notion notifications I split out my
figma notifications I have a special
split inbox that is all of the customer
satisfaction surveys that are coming
through typeform and then finally I've
split out internal team emails versus
external emails
so I have a very
simple but massively effective structure
to how I go through my email
first of all I go to Google Docs notion
figma for me unblocking the engineering
and product teams hyper critical right
see first thing I said how fast we move
is how fast our companies move
then I go to the internal team email
split same deal I want to get back to
those really quickly then I go back to
the customer satisfaction split
this is a little bit more when you're a
scaled company but staying in touch with
what customers are thinking starts to
become the problem so we have to build
solutions to that
then only finally do I do external email
so there's a very specific flow talk
about the software uh kind of process
that you guys follow it seems like I
know you talk to a ton of customers
you're getting insights there and you
guys are shipping these updates in a
pretty quick way how do you build that
culture internally to make sure that
your focus actually solving the
customer's problem versus doing a whole
bunch of other things you guys could be
building
this episode is brought to you by
auradon they are a brand new startup led
by a number of Silicon Valley Legends
who just raised 81 million dollars to
build the future of Internet
infrastructure you're probably wondering
what that means let me explain there are
numerous new disruptive technologies
that are being adopted simultaneously
from blockchain to artificial
intelligence to zero knowledge
Technologies in order to ensure that
these Technologies thrive in this new
world we need new infrastructure and
that is where Ardine comes in they just
launched their first product line called
teraflux which is a Bitcoin miner
powered by the world's first four
nanometer silicon chip technology these
air-cooled single phase and dual phase
emerging cooling miners have unrivaled
speed and efficiency they have Superior
uptime and they leverage a brand new
innovation called Energy tune that
allows miners to dynamically adjust the
energy consumption and Bitcoin hash rate
based on demand response needs of the
electrical grids auradyne is an
ambitious company working on hard
problems I'm really impressed with them
and if you want to check out more you
can go to auradyne.com that's
a-u-r-a-d-i-n-e.com go check them out at
auradon.com today
that are in the same way that you build
a company to achieve anything which is
you make it cultural so this is
literally in the DNA of the company I
mean I remember when I onboarded you
this was over zoom and I mean I've done
probably nearly a thousand of these at
this point and there are people in the
organization for whom this is their job
they've done many thousands of
onboardings
and
hopefully it wasn't too obvious but I
was taking copious notes as we went uh
what you think about the products how
your Gmail workflow was what kind of
volumes of email were you getting what
bugs did you see that you probably
didn't notice because you know as
Founders we see way more bugs than our
users do
and every single time we've onboarded a
person that was the process
so that then goes into a actually a
basically a custom CRM that we built in
the air table to hold all of that
information
whenever anybody emails the company
customer support and we get in the
region of 2000 to two and a half
thousand emails a week
all of those emails are tagged and
triaged and broken down so we built a
custom integration inside of superhuman
we can select the bit of text click a
button and it adds a row to a feedback
table in the database that records who
said it when they said it what the email
address is and it gets tagged against a
feature or a bug that it's relating to
the upshot of that is
when it comes time to build a new
feature let's say I want to build
calendar scheduling
we get to save about three months of
research that a company would normally
do at the start of that so what we do is
we go to the set table we pivot it
around features we say Okay calendar
scheduling and I can see the verbatants
of thousands of customers who've asked
for that thing so we can then build the
thing based on a thousand interviews
that have already happened over the
preceding years ship the thing
and the really cool thing is when it
ships we can now close the loop because
we have thousands of open conversations
it takes manual work but we do it
because it's totally worth it we go back
to every single customer and say Hey you
know that thing that you asked for four
years ago or whenever it was we shipped
it go ahead give it a try tell us how it
feels this blows people away every time
what's the reaction to that oh my God
it's people like how are you tracking
this which is why I know the answer
because I've explained it so many times
now when you look at the team that
you're building where are you finding
the talent and how do you think about
the current environment versus maybe
just two or three years ago when it
seemed like everyone wanted to work at
startups startups were flush with cash
uh it was everyone's going to get rich
quickly it's a little bit tougher now
talk a little bit about the hiring
process
I actually think it's way better now so
we've seen two major changes over the
course of the last few years
we're a San Francisco based company and
before covid
we were I think about 50 people and
everyone was in the Bay Area so nobody
lived more than probably 50 miles away
from the office
obviously that changed immediately
overnight there was no way that we'd be
able to continue to scale in that way
and so we made the decision to hire
across the American time zones so today
we hire in Canada in North America and
in Mexico
and we found amazing levels of
engineering talent in Canada and also in
Mexico that's part of how we've been
able to scale in addition to the rest of
America
had we not made that choice I think it
would have been very difficult to
maintain the caliber of person that we
have
the second thing that's changed is yeah
I mean this industry is going through a
tough time many companies are going to
struggle to grow into their valuations
there will be down rounds there'll be
all kinds of nasty things coming down
the pipe
and this may sound weird but in a way
that's a good thing I think the tourists
have left the people that the people
that are founding companies today they
remind me of the caliber of founder from
2010 2011. right they're special people
the people in this room
these are special people and also the
people that we hire
they're no longer Mercenaries
they're missionaries the number of
conversations you hear or the I mean
it's always going to happen right a
Savvy person is going to want to talk
about compensation and equity and
trajectory and valuation and all of that
those are still supremely important
conversations and you should have
amazing answers to those but the amount
of interview time that goes into that
versus the mission compared to just two
years ago that has dramatically changed
and I think that's the type of person
who wants to work in a startup today
before we finish up I want to bring it
back to productivity uh obviously
email's a huge one what else are you
doing for productivity to make sure that
you're either saving time or you're
getting more value out of the time that
you are spending working on superhuman
yeah for me the biggest change that I've
made over the last few years has been
finally adopting and sticking to a
meditation practice so I had many false
starts over the years
and I realized just that just looking at
the way I've successfully learned habits
in the past I'm the kind of person who
responds extremely well to coaching and
it turns out you can get a coach for
whatever you want
so I found the best meditation coach in
the Bay Area I can intro anyone if they
like his name is Laurent balasek he runs
the peak Leadership Institute and what I
really liked about this guy is
he has a very compelling
meditation practice that's rooted in
Transcendental Meditation there's a
spiritual aspect to it as well which you
can dive into if you want to but you
don't have to that's optional but before
that he was also a venture-backed
Founder twice
and so there's a little bit of Executive
coaching to his practice to his coaching
and
I always feel like he knows what I'm
going through
both when things are going well and also
when times are hard
so he taught me Transcendental
Meditation it was pretty intense the
first few days it was several hours per
day and then we sort of tapered off and
now we meet up once every month or so
just to sort of keep my skill level
topped up
but this has been nothing short of
life-changing I now do this for an hour
a day so half an hour when I wake up
it's the very first thing I do I don't
even let myself get out of bed I set up
right I do the meditation and half an
hour again in the afternoon
and I found that not only am I way
happier that was the first thing I
noticed
I'm way more creative
and I'm much more able to focus for long
periods of time
so it's really hard to think of anything
else that can achieve that kind of
result
when you think of superhuman currently
what's the pitch to customers in terms
of if they use the product what do they
get out of it the reason I ask that is
um Gmail's free and it's really really
hard to compete with something that's
free so you have a paid product it's got
to be so exponentially more valuable I
pay you every month and I think you got
me for life but how do you think about
making it that much better like what is
it doing the Gmail can't so that people
can understand
yeah I mean just starting with General
startup advice and I look for this as an
investor investor in over 100 companies
I actually love it when startups compete
with incumbents because incumbents are
just so busy with the business of being
an incumbent
I met a a Gmail product manager
a week ago and they had the most
depressing story
in nine months all that they've been
able to ship is moving one radio button
in nine months can you imagine that
and this is a well-run company so it's
actually a sound strategy to pick an
incumbent to pick a product that
billions of people use but then you need
to do something very specific you need
to segment the market
you know we're not the first company
to have created an email product that
you pay for
but I think we're the first company in
the space to really break out and to not
just create a product that people pay
for but they do are at a very large
scale
and the way that we were able to do that
was by completely changing the
positioning
the core value proposition of superhuman
is speed and I remember when I was
pitching this was 2017. to the 12 of us
who are in the company at that time hey
folks I think our core value prop should
be speed people looked at me like I lost
my mind
but I'd also just invented the the
products Market fit engine which you may
have come across it's an algorithmic way
to get to products Market fit and I was
like this is what the data shows if we
do this I guarantee you and I can
mathematically prove it we'll get to
product Market fit assuming you believe
in the metric
so that's where we started
and the positioning was key
because it then led to the
realization that if you're the kind of
person
who receives not tens of emails a day
but hundreds that you have to do
something about
you've been historically ignored that no
one has ever built this product for you
in fact no one's ever built products for
you in general and this was the idea
that we've had the consumerization of
the Enterprise but what about the
prosumerization of the Enterprise so we
started there and that was really the
initial core user base for superhuman I
mean since then it's expanded a lot the
fastest growing part of the business is
our team's business so we have a bunch
of people at your company we I see a
bunch of teams here or Founders
representing teams I should say that use
superhuman together and I mean that's
sort of uh
how startups scale is you you start with
a very specific Persona then you have to
get very deliberate about either the
personas or the Industries or the
markets that you're adding after that
and so we're now on that Journey where
can we send people to find out more
about superhuman uh well superhuman.com
pretty easy
I appreciate you coming this has been
fantastic I'm a big fan of the product
and I think that anyone here who's
trying to improve email highly had
suggest it so Raul Vora thank you so
much thank you for having me